chad cool 438 era continues to go down
he has been pitching
pretty good um you know if you haven't
been paying attention the pirates have
won five of his last six starts and in
all those six starts he's given up more
than one run only twice and then two of
those starts just three runs so
chad cool is um getting better as this
season continues
and right to the second baseman rodolfo
castro
one
two last seven starts including that
seven double plays freddie peralta man
freddie making start number four career
against the pirates he's one and one
see those numbers he's first in baseball
an opponent batting average fifth in the
national league and earned run average
six and punch out
his innings
he had defoe out in front lazy little
pop up to adamus a 60 game schedule
keep ryan hayes in the center field
and that'll stay up for lorenzo kane two
men are out one ball two strikes on
reynolds peralta hoping to make it a
three-up three-down frame and he does a
strikeout to end the inning
good start for freddie peralta
[Music]
and he swings it that pitch up and out
of the zone
2-1 pitch to tyrone taylor swing and a
fly ball hit to left gamel back still
back warning track it's over his head
and off the wall in a bounce
tyrone taylor digs into second with a
one-out double man in scoring position
for lorenzo kane
and he hits it on the ground coming to
the plate and taylor's in there
harris dropped the ball kane's green
light 3-0 drives in the first round of
the game how about that jump i'll tell
you the brewers base running has been
terrific this year we don't talk enough
about that
strikes them out
and high fastball
one ball one strike to count
and that ball's hit well center field
kane going back
that's going to stay in the park
he packs a punch boy when he makes
contact
so one a one out here is gregory polanco
now
and he swings at the first pitch he got
under that one
okay it'll camp
two outs
and that one there's a jam shot over to
third base oreos will go the easy way
ground ball on to short
and defo gets in front of it flips in on
the first one out
oh nice smooth little pickup there by
philip evans
because nobody forgets the uh
adamus sends one deep to right center
that's off the wall
and adamus on his way to second with a
double man he just missed a homer gotta
think fastball
nope he throws his best slider tonight
actually curveball 83.
two and two the count
man he got him change up and a strikeout
for freddie peralta he gets that thing
going man
and
waste no time a punch out
third k for peralta turned around so
fast for the brewers one one pitch hit
on the ground to third urias gobbles it
up to throw to first in time and it's a
one two three inning
batted ball the second base by key brian
hayes got in on his hands
peralta's first offering to him
fly ball shallow center racing in his
kane and he's underneath him but he's
there to make the catch
one and two the count on castro
runner goes penis throw right on the bag
gammel is out
wait so two pitch swinging a line drive
hit towards right polanco back it's over
his head and going to be off the wall on
the bounce uria's digging for two here's
the throw not in time head first slide
luis suryas he's into second with the
double and the pitch and swinging the
ground ball right to third hayes looks
back the runner uria stays at second in
the throat of first then lead off double
still standing at second base golden
wong waits he's over two he's bounced
out twice
and he lost him cool upset
missed with a fastball and now william
thomas who's got two of the four hits in
the game a single a double and there
goes
runners
and caught between first and second is
wong evans has to look toward the plate
and get a tag out before the runner
scores
beautiful big break right there good
heads up play by michael perez brewers
run themselves out of an inning
around the area there's a nice play by
arias throw to first oh it's in time
used the grass to his advantage uris
what a play that was man
philip evans robbed of a base hit luis
orria's continues to shine defensively
at third base over two for rowdy he's
struck out and popped out there he goes
the pitch swing and fly ball hit towards
right center back polanco all the way
back it's off the top of the fence
willia thomas is going to score all the
way from first base as rowdy teles with
an rbi double makes it two nothing
brewers
taylor doubled in the second inning get
a rocket over the head of gamble and
left to les hit second base and that
one's on the ground and that's
by the third baseman hayes into left
field teles will score
tyrone taylor on his way to second base
the throw gets away it's gonna be
another double for taylor three nothing
milwaukee here in the sixth inning so
manny pena two out rbi opportunity
runners at first and second
manny pina sends one to left field back
goes gamble and this one is gone manny
pina
a three-run home run the pineapple pina
busted open six nothing brewers
another huge inning for the brewers
they've been uh coming up with some big
innings lately a five run sixth inning
oh and two
hit the top of the plate peralta gloves
it shovels it and out at first
with some nice glove work that's a heck
of a play by peralta as well
in that category the whip stat that's a
fastball strike three call
two down for rowdy teles
six nothing brewers here top of the
seventh inning okay very interesting
teles in the air left center field got
some carry
and this one is gone oh my goodness
rowdy teles speaking of long home runs
you just don't see many left-handers go
oppo
there in pittsburgh
seven to nothing brewers tolez's eighth
home run of the year he is really
feeling it at the plate my goodness i
mean that is a blast and here's manny
pina three run home run his last time in
the sixth one one pitch
swinging a fly ball hit the deep center
way back reynolds pina again
a two-run shot for manny pena the
brewers have a nine-nothing lead on the
second home run of the night from the
brewers catcher manny pina
oh and kane shoots one to right
a base hit on the efus and this will
bring in two runs lorenzo kane have a
series o2 pitch
reyes rips one
down the line that is a fair ball
kane strolls in manny pena to third base
and that should do it wong's got it
flips the first ball game over shutout
complete the brewers have swept the
pirates here in pittsburgh the final
tonight 12-0 nothing